[Music]
all right welcome thank you all for
coming
my name is Matt Duffy ler I'm a software
engineer with Google in New York really
excited to be here with Tom from ways
Andy from wet flick Netflix it's close
second talk to you all about spinnaker
we've all been working together for a
few years but it's nice to have a good
reason to get together in the same place
once in a while so I'm just gonna be a
minute I'm gonna introduce Tom and Andy
and then I'll be back in a while
told my wife we were doing this talk and
I want to come up with a waste joke to
give Tom a hard time and she tried to
talk me out of it so I should just be
nice and then we were thinking we can
let Tom come up and get into it and then
every time he's just about to the
interesting part I'll just loudly
interrupt him to warm warm of a car up
ahead or a mattress on the highway or
the cops or something but but I won't
yeah
so I'll be back in a little bit talked a
lot about what Google's doing with
spinnaker and for now here's Tom thanks
Matt thanks Matt in 2008 a small
start-up called wave was formed we hit
the ground running
with a mission to help our users
outsmart traffic together to achieve
that mission we needed very fast
feedback from our users how do we get it
we shipped off four features and we
shipped them fast we did that using a
few developers deploying to a few
physical servers however we couldn't
scale on physical hardware so then then
we move to the cloud once we learned the
cloud things really start getting
complicated
till now developers were able to deploy
software to production on their own but
as the amount of users grew we had to
start using auto scaling massively until
we ended up with hundreds of auto
scaling
and thousands of instances the more we
grew the more severe the problem became
until eventually the entire development
team lost this capability to deliver
software to production it simply
evaporated and that was mainly due to
lack of tooling back then to deploy one
back-end service to production
developers needed to create images
deploy them to multiple geographically
sharded auto-scaling groups usually in a
rolling fashion and robots were
extremely painful so this job moved to
the asari team which is in charge of
waste production but at least we were
able to grow so we started out with a
goal of fast feedback from our users but
as we hit a certain scale of ways users
developers and micro services the
complexity of software deployment went
up dramatically so things were kind of
grinding to a halt
there was this bottleneck but nobody
really realized just how bad it was once
developers couldn't ship as fast as they
wanted to they started batching features
into the same release and it became
riskier to deploy it like that to
production even though they wanted to
ship fast once features were completed
they simply could not and because of the
batching of features and bug fixes
releases became extremely large and it's
nasty to work like this because by now
your lot you are deploying very large
pieces of software that could break the
system and when it breaks it's not clear
which one of the ten features just
released caused the problem so solving
it becomes much harder from the asari
team perspective the team is working
like crazy to ship software but it's
never enough
so everybody's disappointed and there's
a ton of pressure from our users
perspective features arrive slowly and
the system could definitely be more
stable so we look for solutions
lucky for us Netflix was gracious enough
to share both their experience and the
software they've built to solve this
problem which is spinnaker so what
exactly is spinnaker well it's an open
source multi-cloud continuous delivery
platform for deploying for leasing
software changes with high velocity and
confidence so for us spinnaker is
essentially a shortcut to achieving what
we want and what we want is fast safe
and repeatable software delivery with
easy relaxed
so we deployed spinnaker throughout all
of the development teams at ways and
this is how reality changed as a
developer I could I now have the
feedback cycle I need because right now
deployments are back to a single click
operation and it's all self-service I
can ship I can get feedback and the core
of the matter is that I have complete
autonomy and because I have complete
autonomy I don't need to rely on the SRE
team anymore which are now free to work
on system stability and scalability
which is a good thing so we have I'm
sorry and the best part is that our
users get features and bug fixes much
quicker so we have happier users and
because we're shipping smaller amounts
of features each time the risk of
service disruption goes down and when
there is a problem solving it becomes
much easier when you see the immediate
feedback of your work and have complete
autonomy it gives you more Drive and
motivation to go even quicker take more
risks and transform the service to be
even more amazing so that explains
things on a super high level if we drill
down Spinnaker's power really comes from
its abstraction and powerful pipeline
engine it allows us to bridge between
multiple technology stacks in our case
VMs and kubernetes and cloud providers
it's a sweet spot between just the
amount of abstraction on top of each
technology but it is still able to
control each stack precisely that's a
bit contradictory with spinnaker somehow
manages to pull it off once applications
are using spinnaker everybody in the
company has this single pane of glass
which can be used to perform the daily
work of deploying software and the main
point is that it feels the same no
matter what technology stack you are on
whether you are on VMs kubernetes app
engine or any cloud provider supported
so life was good for a while as you well
know when you solve one problem two new
problems are created and they were
created one of them was managing this
crazy amount of pipelines in production
and the other was that we were moving
too fast
now we wanted to move fast so why is
that a problem well it's a problem
because it's risky and we'll get to that
in a moment so by now we had over 1,000
deployment pipelines in production all
of them were managed through the
spinnaker UI and it became a huge pain
point for the teams to operate because
each of these pipelines were essentially
duplicates of one
with slight changes in between them so
for example adding a stage to all of
these production pipelines
is too much of a risk for production
there's actually no one willing to do it
so we started looking for solutions and
the idea was to build a paved road
deployment pipeline something that 80%
of the development teams could use and
be happy with while the rest of them
could change it and adapt it to their
needs but still use it would happen in
the past was that each team had their
own set of pipelines and when they had a
good idea
it remained local to that team now with
the paved road pipeline templates these
changes are done centrally so all of
these ideas and best practices are
available throughout the entire company
so we started off with a simple payroll
pipeline it has a bake smoke test or
stage and deploy to production each car
represents one specific version of an
application now from the animation you
can see that what used to be 1,000
separate pipelines are now all using
this paved road pipeline and this
encapsulate the best practices we know
of how to deliver software to production
and it has also finally become
manageable remember that problem of
moving too fast
well this change essentially raised the
speed limit of the company from 60 miles
an hour to 600 miles an hour and when
you do that new risks will appear now we
wanted to move extremely fast but it's
risky so we needed more safeguards in
order to solve this problem we added a
canary stage we evolved
our payroll pipeline let's see how it
looks so now she's checking each version
and deciding okay okay to do that we
simply duplicated the previous paved
road pipeline add in a canary stage
which Matt will talk about later in
depth and then sent one of the
applications to the new paved road
pipeline tested it and once we were
happy we disabled the old one and sent
everybody to the new road so by now
developers woke up one morning and had
an option for a safer deployment
pipeline they could now move from a
deploy and revert model to a canary
model and this means that they can catch
problems early on when it effects only a
slight percentage of the users let's say
one team didn't want to run all of the
stages well they could simply bypass it
they could pick and choose whatever
stages they wanted to run and if another
team wanted a person to approve
deploying to production well they could
just inject a new manual judgment stage
right before the deployment reproduction
working with favorite pipelines means
that any enhancements or fixes that we
want to make to the pipeline's are
immediately reflected across the entire
organization and that makes it easy to
make decisions and have them automated
throughout there are some important
technical aspects to even all of this is
done as code with code reviews sent to
teammates before each change to this
paved road system so tracking and
rolling back is pretty easy we have a
few of these paved roads at ways one is
for micro services and the other is for
our
data layer cassandra we actually run
Bluegreen deployments when upgrading or
resizing our cassandra fleet and we use
pipeline templates and spinnaker to
manage all of this for example if we
want to stand up a new multi cloud
Cassandra cluster all it takes is
writing a tiny config file generating
the pipeline templates for them and
running them in spinnaker previously
this would have taken way too much time
and was prone to error and now it's
fully automatic so for us that's pretty
amazing so that's more or less the end
of my story
well the way story today I believe that
a new developer at ways has complete
autonomy and can't focus on what matters
mainly thanks to spinnaker wases
recently joined the development effort
around spinnaker and we're specifically
focused on adding some sre concepts like
service level objectives and error
budgets I believe that once spinnaker is
aware of an error budget for an
application some interesting things can
start to happen for example when a
service is almost out of error budget
the canary system could automatically
run longer to gain more confidence in
new versions or perhaps something that
was previously fully automatic now has a
manual judgment stage kicking in because
of the error budgets as happy as we are
to be part of the spinnaker community
they wouldn't be a spinnaker community
if it weren't for Andy Glover and its
excellent team and Netflix for starting
this project we're lucky to have Andy
here today with us Andy
[Applause]
so I gotta warn you my um my slides
aren't half as cool as Tom's my name is
Andy Glover and I I run delivery
engineering at Netflix we are the
spinner cartoon and I do work at Netflix
and I want to say thanks to my good
friend Matt who works at Google for the
the phenomenal introduction earlier so
again very happy to be here
so at Netflix we we value speed indeed
speed of innovation is our competitive
advantage we firmly believe that if we
aren't fast our competitors certainly
will be what's more our members you all
Henny won here a Netflix number see you
thank you thank you very much we love
you and we're firmly convinced that you
all demand that we knew that we move
fast when's the last time you got upset
when you put something in your when you
ordered something from Amazon it didn't
arrive the same day so if we don't you
know move fast we're pretty sure that
you'll you'll go to our competitors so
whether it's to address a bug add new
features or even add new content you
name it if we don't move fast and meet
your expectations we're convinced you'll
go elsewhere
we also firmly believe that the faster
we we learn the faster we evolve and
continue to win moments of truth Netflix
is a global company our service is used
by more than a hundred and thirty
million people every day and we're
available in over in almost 200
countries and to facilitate our growth
we have a global infrastructure we
leverage AWS and operate in multiple
regions around the world moreover we
also leverage a commercial content
delivery network as well as our own
fleet of globally distributed servers
for content distribution called
open connect appliances
yes so operating at this level of scale
requires sophisticated tooling that
ultimately makes it easy for development
teams to move fast with a high degree of
consonants as you saw with Waze and so
that's why we built a continuous
delivery platform or excuse me a
continuous delivery and if the structure
management platform which we accordingly
named spinnaker and the key thing is
spinnaker was built leveraging the
myriad lessons learned from multiple
systems that enabled continuous delivery
at Netflix over the past number of years
and so orchestrating the delivery of
software assets via spinnaker
facilitates moving fast at a global
scale it has accelerated our time to
market spinnaker empowers teams to make
rapid changes with confidence and thus
enables a focus on building the right
product for you all it has also improved
developer productivity and efficiency so
yeah that that's my paved road slide
thanks Tom appreciate it
[Laughter]
so yeah spinnaker is a platform that
enables all the benefits of continuous
delivery and accordingly it acts as a
paved road for making it painless to
take ideas and put them in front of
users rapidly this pave note this paved
road enables teams at Netflix to focus
on their charters and not on the nuances
of delivery so ultimately spinnaker
makes developers lives easier and
because it's an extensible platform
spinnaker provides a means to plug into
a greater infrastructure of integrated
tools and other platforms like chaos
monkey squeeze testing which we call
citrus and automated canary analysis
which Tom alluded to it is awesome
slides and which I believe there's gonna
be a demo as well we call it Chi anta
and so developers who use spinnaker they
get all these tools for free without
having to write all the
code to switch together a complex or
just use me stitch together a complex
delivery process like people were doing
before spinnaker at Netflix their arts
any centralized DevOps teams or release
teams teams that Netflix owned their own
destiny building their own pipelines and
spinnaker and managing their apps in
production they leverage what's
available out of the box and spinnaker
but and this is key they're free to
build on top of spinnaker adding their
needs so as to efficiently reap the
benefits of continuous delivery so the
needs of various teams at Netflix has
resulted in a powerful extensions within
spinnaker that enabled not only rapid
and reliable delivery to AWS anyone here
heard of AWS had to snake that in but
also to Akamai which is a content
delivery network and to our own
container cloud called Titus you can
think of it a lot like kubernetes but
the innovations don't stop there
spinnaker has also been extended to
facilitate delivery of firmware updates
to that fleet of global servers that I
called open connect appliances which are
distributed across the the world in data
centers closest to where you live so
when you actually hit play the video
itself is streamed to you from that box
not from the cloud so to speak AWS
spinnaker enables the safe manipulation
of feature flags that is you can create
a complex delivery pipeline for changing
runtime data in production without
shooting yourself in the foot
furthermore spinnaker now enables the
delivery and management of libraries
across Netflix so you can imagine there
are teams at Netflix that potentially
don't or do not own a service that
facilitates streaming they ultimately
own a library that facilitates streaming
and they too now are using spinnaker to
affect delivery
those libraries to other teams and
managing those libraries once they're in
the infrastructure as Tom said spinnaker
is open source with a strong and vibrant
community including Netflix Google
Google Waze but also folks like Target
who's here at this conference my good
friends from pivotal Under Armour
Microsoft and that's just naming a few
of the large companies investing in this
platform everyone is on is innovating
within the platform so not only does
spinnaker integrate with major cloud
vendors but there are integrations with
OpenStack pivotal Cloud Foundry DCOs
and even Oracle bare-metal cloud
what's more the community is building
new pipeline stages command-line tools
for interacting with and managing
spinnaker and even new canta metric
sources like stack driver and data dog
this will all make more sense once you
see the demo of canary analysis and
that's just some of the innovations that
this community is building within the
spinnaker ecosystem and so I think all
of us within the community would agree
that rapid and reliable global software
delivery has never been more easy than
it is today and with that I will turn it
over to my good friend Matt from Google
[Applause]
thanks Andy
and thanks Tom for setting the bar so
high for animations and slides that none
of us will will ever measure up all
right so Tom mentioned earlier that
spinnaker enables his development teams
to push changes in a production with
confidence and and I gather he has some
kind of confidence because he's going to
allow me to push a change live into the
production environment at ways so if I
could have the demo laptop please all
right so we'll kick this off we'll let
it run in the background and then we'll
come back and talk about exactly what's
going on so cross your fingers for the
demo gods will let that go and if I
could have the presentation laptop again
the one with the slides the other one
with the slides thank you all right so
it's gonna push a change the idea here
is that um we'll let it work it'll take
maybe 10 minutes or so we'll come back
and poke around the configuration and
the execution of that pipeline it's a
live change against ways and are you
planning on I'm skipping out early
bedtime to use ways to get out of San
Francisco
but that's on you alright so in the past
Google's disclosed many numbers about
our internal source control system and
these are these are incredible numbers
my my data is out of date but things
like over a billion files tens of
millions of commits tens of thousands of
software developers all working out of
the same giant repository I want to talk
about a different kind of different set
of numbers now the goal here is not
really to leave you with an impression
about like Google's internal scale or
complexity but more about just our
commitment to the spinnaker project and
the surrounding community so I'm part of
the spinnaker team we work full-time on
spinnaker in the last year or so we've
more than doubled in size we have 13
full-time software engineers full-time
product manager a technical program
manager and a dedicated engineering
manager he brought stickers he's around
here somewhere
what
we're doing these are these are some of
the things we work on we support
customers and users not all of the users
we work with our Google customers many
are but not all we're in the slack
channel all the time just helping people
it's good for the community and it's
good for us because we find out what
people are interested in and what's
important to the companies so it lets us
focus we built out a large release
workflow for building testing and
releasing spinnaker itself the project
is 9 10 11 I don't know how many
independent micro services it's a big
complicated project before we built this
release workflow folks were pretty much
just running it at head cloned all the
repos figure out how to configure it
fight llamó run it ask questions on
slack we built out a process to do
regularly scheduled integration tests
and have versioned releases across all
these independent services including
change logs pegging changes to future
versions and so on the goal there was to
really make it you know easier to
install and manage and we'll talk more
about that in a second but also to give
confidence to enterprises that it's it's
a real project a real product as a
version you can count on it will will
release patch releases when important
things are discovered and and so on on
the topic of installing and configuring
spinnaker its well the idea is that you
can install it you can get it running
and then when you have a an issue in the
past we had to go and say try this llamó
file make this change and so on so we
built a tool to make that easier called
halyard we'll talk more about that in a
second but I think it's a pretty good
example of something we built entirely
out in the open in the open source that
makes everybody's lives working with
spinnaker quite a bit easier we also
work on internal usage of spinnaker
there are some Google teams pushing
changes an internal Google
infrastructure using spinnaker and we'll
talk more about that in the coming
months as well alright so the obvious
question well not who is that because
that's somebody who works at ways
because I've seen him when I visited but
why why such an investment in the
spinnaker project so there are there are
lots of reasons the first is that the
primitives and operations that spinnaker
defines a line really really well with
our internal best
practices things that folks do on
internal proprietary Google systems
match up perfectly well with what
Spinnaker's is bringing to the community
another another good reason for us
convergence
whether it's open source software
state-of-the-art software like spinnaker
or our various cloud offerings that GCP
is offering to customers the more we can
align those things with what we do
internally the better for customers the
better for for hiring new folks at
Google and so on it's just it's an
all-around good thing Tom talked a bit
about abstractions the idea with
spinnaker isn't that it creates perfect
abstractions over every underlying cloud
platform but that it creates like a
commonality so you have a consistent
experience it's just consistent enough
that you can find your way and hopefully
each development team doesn't have to
become an expert on every cloud platform
that they're targeting the the
operations themselves are our
abstractions for and it does help you
kind of get out of the weeds in terms of
like making images and pushing new
versions of your software out into
production doing rollbacks managing
traffic running Canaries all these
things are defined as first-class
primitives and they'll let you think at
a slightly higher level rather than like
fighting every nuance and detail of the
underlying platforms lastly Google's
tied at the hip with open-source
software
we have-we contribute to tons of
open-source projects we use open source
software ourselves throughout the Google
stack so it's everywhere spinnaker is
really just one more example of Google
being part of the broader open source
community so in terms of Google's
involvement with spinnaker it started
maybe four or so years ago late summer
2014 one person working part time on the
project is a 20% project and it took off
from there
we started off with adding support for
GCE and then kubernetes and GK and App
Engine and so on and as each platform
becomes available we've we've continued
dad's support and then we've given a lot
of that back to the community by helping
other folks some of whom look like
competitors some are competitors but
we're all kind of working together out
in the open and sharing what we all know
about adding support for additional
platforms and it's been been pretty
rewarding
so I wrote make it easy to install and
manage and I remember there's gonna be a
video and I cross it out I wrote it
easier it's not easy but it's it's
hopefully easier this is halyard that I
was describing a moment ago it's much
better than it was it's it's definitely
easier it's not simple it's a big
complicated thing that's just all there
is to it
the types of organizations that adopt
spinnaker are large organizations
typically maybe serving multiple teams
across multiple projects multiple cloud
platforms with lots of complexity and
variability and that requires a pretty
sophisticated platform spinnaker itself
has all these individual services that
can each horizontally scale as they need
to and they all kind of cooperate to
produce his platform so it's not it's
not trivial to install or manage but
halyard lets you do it lets you do it on
VMs on containers in an atomic fashion
or a distributed fashion handles no
downtime upgrades and flippin every
option on and off and and everything in
between
and I wrote advanced topics I wasn't
sure what to call it but the idea here
is that beyond sort of making sure all
that table stakes are there to make
enterprises happy
we work on a lot of things that I would
describe as like adding in best
practices and smarts into the platform
just as we learn things over time we try
to build more and more of that in so
companies can adopt this encourage their
own teams to follow best practices but
also kind of share back what we've
learned so not everybody has to create
like a canary analysis service from
scratch which is what we're going to
talk about next
so this canta like Andy mentioned it
it's an automated canary analysis
service that's that's a mouthful it's a
recently released spinnaker service we
partnered with another team at Netflix
part of which is now I think part of the
spinnaker team proper at Netflix debt
team delivery engineering team at
Netflix so we partnered to take a
service that they've been running for
many years inside of Netflix which was
like battle-hardened through quite a bit
of adoption they're called ACA and kind
of reimagine it and evolve it to be a
bit more open and extensible and support
a broader set of use cases and that's
what Kayenta is and we did it with the
team that had been working on that
service all along
it was open-sourced a few months back
some of the key things we wanted to
accomplish out of the gate or to make
sure that it supports all of the cloud
platforms that spinnaker itself supports
so it's not geared towards any one
platform in particular so right out of
the gate the day it was released it
could be used with GC with AWS with
kubernetes every other supported
platform it's it doesn't really have an
opinion about the underlying platform in
addition it supports an extensible set
of metric services so we released it was
support for stackdriver
with support for Atlas which is Netflix
his own time series database support for
Prometheus the armory folks I saw some
of them bouncing around and it's support
for data dog a community member added
support for influx DB right after was
released so it's a growing set of a
metric services it supports all the way
up through UI integration it's pretty
cool to work and then we'll see some of
that in a moment
lastly pluggable Canary judges the
initially supported judge is the one
that was in use that Netflix is still in
use I think it's just called the ACA
judge but we can call the Netflix judge
there are other judges in development
Google has some judges internally that
we're working on integrating but the
idea is its extensible and people can
can do what makes sense there you're not
stuck to one particular approach so this
is going to be its kind of quick and
it's just really a taste of what can two
offers we think it's a very good example
of the kinds of things we're doing
really to push the envelope in the
continuous delivery space there are
webinars and things that we've done that
you can find online for more details
about Caliente all right so this brings
us back to the pipeline so what that
pipeline does and we'll look at it in a
second
it orchestrates a canary release for a
particular ways service when a new image
becomes available
the idea with Canarian is that it really
should be used for any kind of change it
can be a binary change like a new image
is available it can be a config change
and infrastructure change but the bottom
line is you have some change you want to
make against something running in
production and you want to do it in a
safe way you want to determine in an
automated of a fashion as possible
whether it's it's a safe change or not
and you want to make sure to have a very
narrow blast radius and then over time
as you gain confidence in that release
you roll it out
to a broader and broader scope so this
particular one is just a new binary
image becoming available this is the
service that it affects it's a ways
text-to-speech service it you know
generates real-time audio when you're
using Waze for navigation it's a global
service it's available behind a global
load balancer an HTTP load balancer it's
requested miles and events so hopefully
no Waze users were harmed in the making
of this demo but it's not really
sensitive to latency because it happens
way in advance what we're doing here is
we took the running production image and
we changed it and we changed it to
artificially introduce some latency into
the backend so the load balancer that's
that's forwarding traffic to all of
these individual backends is also
reporting to stack driver metrics on
things like back-end latency and in this
case we artificially increase that
latency so the metrics that are recorded
in stack driver are going to show a
higher number for that particular metric
and then we configured an extremely
simple canary analysis that looks at
just that one back-end latency metric
and tries to determine with some
automated statistical tests whether
there's a significant difference there
and this is the basic path of automated
canary analysis you find the strong
indicators of safety for your particular
use case your application you configure
the canary analysis to look those things
up you make sure they're being published
from your application and your
infrastructure and then you apply at run
time these statistical techniques which
we can talk more about and then a
scoring strategy is applied and it's
compared to thresholds that you define
for your use case your pipelines and
then it's treated as a gate for that
deployment okay in this case it's it's a
trivial example while it's running
against live systems we gave it at our
six minutes to warm up and and four
minutes of run time so we're gonna get
for one minute data points it's a very
small set of data it's just for
demonstration in experimenting with it
we ended up turning off the sensitivity
of the judge a bit because the judge
would basically say this isn't really
enough data to have a lot of confidence
so we we said well we still want to have
an answer all right if I could have
their demo laptop please
all right so it should finish in about
ten seconds we'll look at the
configuration of this while we wait so
this is a pretty typical pipeline with a
canary release what we encourage for
best practices when you're configuring
your own canary is don't provision the
new canary resources and compare it to
everything else that's already been
running in production for some period of
time provision a new set of resources
using what's running in production as
the baseline and sibling using the
canary configuration so it's a very
apples to apples comparison use the same
infrastructure provision them at the
same point in time and the single only
Delta should be the change you want to
canary in this case it's a new binary
image so that's why you see here there's
there are a couple of lookups so find
the baseline image find the canary image
and we're just using a tag based lookups
say what's running in production what's
the new image that's available what's
the change we want a canary
then we deploy a new baseline and a new
canary in parallel and then we have the
canary analysis stage and the way
spinnaker works each of these stages
completes before the next one it's quite
standard control flow you can see the
control flow joins back together at the
canary analysis stage the only thing
worth keeping in mind here is you have
these two deploys these are provisioning
here we're running on GCE VMs it works
the same on whatever platform but in
this case these are GCE VMs running and
managed instance groups those stages
won't be considered complete until
they're considered healthy based on a
number of things load balancers machine
health and so on so the canary analysis
is quite straightforward in this case
it's a real-time analysis means which
means we're waiting for metrics to be
published collected you can do a
retrospective analysis as well we refer
to a config and think of that as like a
templated query that's also done through
the UI I don't think we're going to show
that now and then you can see a warm-up
period and you can configure a lifetime
and you can break it down into multiple
intervals and so on and below that it
says what are the what's the pair of
things I want to compare and in this
case we're comparing a baseline and a
canary server group that were just
provisioned I can make it a little
bigger that were just provisioned
upstream and then there's some
additional configuration for the query
so when this thing runs
the canary gods smiled upon us so this
failed which is what we wanted okay and
you can see us as canary score is not
above the marginal score threshold and
it does you can see this little red
triangle it's admonishing us that we
probably if we're gonna rely on this
where production want to have more data
points than that we have we'll see in a
moment but I'm sure we have three or
four data points so this is gonna back
out a little bit this is what standard
set of execution details look like for a
spinnaker pipeline in this case it's
that canary stage but you can see the
configuration which said you know what
are we comparing what's the warm-up
period how long does the canary run and
then the individual stat the statuses of
the individual tasks that make up that
canary stage and this is I think a
pretty decent example of what you would
have to do if you wanted to script this
by hand you have to do is provisioning
you have to configure this thing to wait
for some period of time you have to make
sure things are healthy then you have to
run the actual analysis which means go
off build queries fetch the metrics
figure out how to compare them you can
probably find off-the-shelf statistical
tests and you could probably make all of
that work but the idea with Spinnaker's
to make all of that consumable I mean
we're trying to kind of let you work
with a higher level of primitive and the
canary analysis is is the latest example
of that
so this completed if we look at the
results we can drill down and now this
is one metric it's very simple so the
graph is there's also quite simple but
you can see on the left the name of that
metric you can see that the
classification logic determined it to be
high so the canary was high with respect
to the baseline in this case the only
score we possibly could have gotten a
zero or 100 because we only have the one
metric so you can't use any weighted
scoring or anything and then you can see
the two lines across hopefully can see
the two lines across the graph the
canary is blue and the baseline is maybe
golden Axelrod I don't know what color
that is but you have the two lines there
and then at the bottom there are some
simple statistical details you can see
it said it got three data points for
each and the nice thing about the way we
surface this is that everything's
available so you can actually drill down
right from the UI and you can see the
the resulting queries that were expanded
and executed in this case against
stackdriver but it works the same no
matter
underlying system so you can see the
metric you can see the queries and you
can see the actual data points that were
returned from from stackdriver all right
if I could have this slides laptop again
don't need the video all right so so
what's next
I think we've given a pretty good
example of where we are now and we want
to talk about what's what's coming in
the coming months the spinnaker
community itself is pretty warm and
welcoming and like I said tons of folks
are always in the slack channel always
willing to help but the code base at
Stowe itself is still kind of like a
tough nut to crack so we want to figure
out how to make it easier for other
folks to get involved we've lately been
writing more like developer guides and
we're hosting workshops and this is we
the whole community not just just Google
but but this is one of the main things
we're focused on at the moment also to
really formalize some of our processes
and procedures in terms of how the
spinnaker community operates and like
how people can become committers and
those kinds of things they're set of
cloud platforms is always continuing to
grow their support for the sinkhole
artifacts which is the idea of instead
of embedding logic deep within spinnaker
to understand like what comes from
Jenkins or what comes from a container
registry externalize that information so
an artifact would say this type of thing
from this location with this address and
this metadata so we call that artifacts
but we're making that more consumable
and adding support for additional
systems the canary stage that we showed
had upstream deployment stages and then
later on those things you provisioned to
do the comparison have to be cleaned up
we're adding support directly into the
canary stage for doing that
orchestration to make it make it easier
to configure canary release there's a
CLI which at present lets you
programmatically publish and interact
with pipelines or broadening the set of
capabilities of the CLI there's work
underway inside of Netflix for the time
being to add support for a sequel
back-end there's an alternative for
in-flight workflow representation
provide more durability and some other
some other capabilities and there are
several streams of work
under way involving configuration is
code from manifest oriented deployments
to approaches where you declare the
desired state and then it's constantly
trying to achieve that state on some
schedule and a bunch of other related
bits and just think of it as you know a
spectrum from I do everything with a UI
and a wizard and fill in fields or I
check in my manifest somewhere and then
whether it's a source control system or
some system that supports buckets and
then spinnaker tries to achieve that
state all right best is you have to come
in terms of getting involved we have a
site that has tons of information there
code labs tutorials there's
documentation reference architectures
there's all kinds of information up
there we have the slack channel where
there's there are people in there 24
hours a day always willing to answer
questions there's a discourse community
forum there are I don't know how many
github repos but that's the Umbrella
repo that sort of start that's where
most of the issues are tracked so that's
a good starting point and I don't want
to forget we're having a summit in
October in Seattle looks like it's going
to be huge
come join us it's it's open that's not
just for folks who already involved in
the spinnaker community it's for people
who want to get involved whether it's
developers or users or or partners or
anything else so please come join us
[Music]